[Music]
mark gulped down a few aspirin with his
orange juice
grimacing at the bitter combination of
tastes on his tongue
his head was like a massive pulsing slug
thrumming loudly to the rhythm of his
heart
his stomach was coiled and greasy rachel
stood at the stove with her back to him
she was cooking eggs and he hoped to
christ she wasn't making him any
because the stench of them made his
gorge rise she'd said good morning to
him when he'd shuffled into the room
even though it was past 11 30. she'd
given him a small naked smile
her eyes looked puffy she hadn't said
anything since then
and mark didn't much blame her he
wondered if it would ever be the same
again
could ever be the same for them after
last night
[ __ ] when had he ever been as drunk as
he was last night he didn't think he
ever had been
but it had been a nightmare week he'd
been demoted at work
the damn car had broken down on the
freeway his mother had had her third
stroke
all excuses he knew but didn't they
count for something
he'd never been much of a drinker but
when saturday had finally come
he felt an inescapable urge to blot the
past week from his mind
soak it up like a sponge soaks up water
or blood
his head throbbed anew the aspirin not
even making a dent it seemed
what the hell was he thinking about
blood for the only blood he'd seen so
far was in the mirror
in the veins tracing his yellowed
eyeballs and in his dreams
it could have been different though
christ knew how easily it could have
been different
rachel came and sat across from him at
the table she hadn't made him any eggs
and he silently thanked her
instead she set a small plate of plain
toast and a mug of hot coffee before him
flashing him that almost there smile she
looked so weary
he could have kissed her and started to
do it or at least tell her
but then the fight last night and the
memory of the dreams came back to him in
a flood
he felt his cheeks redden and he dropped
his gaze from hers
concentrating on his toast how could he
have done it
he had almost killed her his hand
squeezing her throat
her stricken bulging face a blur below
his
he had wanted to crush the life from her
in the fever dreams he had had afterward
after they had both calmed down and
talked and cried and made an unsteady
piece
he actually had killed her just
tightened his grip until she'd begun to
turn blue
until she had gone limp in his arms the
knife she'd been holding and swinging at
him had hit the carpet with a metallic
thump
he peered up at her to see if she had
somehow caught the drift of his thoughts
she was staring into space her eggs
forgotten and going cold on her plate
she was lost in her own recollections he
supposed
the worst part mark mused was that those
dreams were so
goddamned real after he had killed her
he had stood there panting the alcohol
coursing through his body like an
electric current
he could feel the sweat beating on his
palms his upper lip
he was still so drunk that he could
barely stand up straight and for a long
moment he just held her as though she
had simply fallen asleep
not fully comprehending what he had done
after a few minutes he had draped her
across the couch
and then stationed himself in the easy
chair staring at her lifeless form
his fingers tented under his chin in the
dream he felt as though he sat there for
hours
his drunk slowly wearing off realization
slowly dawning
it came to him that he'd have to do
something with her get rid of her
somehow
he racked his brains the backyard hell
no too many stray dogs in the area
digging around
too many neighbors too suspicious then
he remembered that campground they used
to go to near the spring when they were
first married it wasn't far but the
woods around it were thick
it seemed remote if anyone stumbled on
her body he'd just say that she left him
that someone must have picked her up
how unlucky for her how tragic he could
gather up her clothes and drop them at
goodwill or something
no one would know he was startled out of
his reverie by her flat voice
what do you want to do today she was
looking at him
he hadn't eaten any of his breakfast and
the coffee mug was lukewarm but still
brimming
he forced himself to take a bite of the
toast the coarse fibers of the bread
like sandpaper in his mouth
i don't know really i still have a
terrible headache she looked away as if
he said something indecent
he tried to eat a few bites more but his
stomach fluttered a warning
right on the edge of sickness he sipped
some of the coffee instead but that was
almost as bad
i'm so sorry about everything rachel he
said suddenly surprising even himself
i promise you nothing like that will
ever happen again
he thought he saw her eyes shining with
tears let's not talk about it anymore
she said all right abruptly she picked
up her untouched food and carried it
back into the kitchen
where she scraped it into the trash with
unnecessary force
mark took his own dishes to the sink and
without a word went back upstairs to
take a shower
he couldn't stop thinking about that
stupid dream about taking her body up to
the campground in a black plastic bag
of dumping it in some thick bushes and
covering it with leaves and loose dirt
he'd had another dream too after that
one in the second dream rachel had
killed him
stabbed him over and over until the
blood ran in rivers
until his world spiraled down to a
featureless black
he toweled off and went into the bedroom
rachel was still downstairs
he could hear the television going hear
her moving around
he opened the closet to grab some
clothes just knocking around clothes he
thought he certainly wasn't planning on
doing anything or going anywhere
until his hangover subsided the clothes
hanging in the closet looked funny to
him
and for a moment he couldn't understand
why then it came to him
all rachel's clothes were gone he
blinked and rubbed his eyes
no there they were all rachel's dresses
and slacks and jewel tone blouses
hanging where they always hung on the
left side what the [ __ ]
i'm never drinking again he thought now
i'm seeing [ __ ]
he dressed quickly trying not to think
too hard about what he'd seen
or hadn't seen he corrected himself it
bothered him because he'd dreamed it
he dreamed about taking all her clothes
out of the closet making it look like
she just picked up and left him
pity really but those are the breaks he
noticed his hands shaking as he buttoned
his shirt
stop damn it it was only a dream mark
made his way downstairs and sat on the
couch where rachel's body had lay in his
dream
in real life she was in the easy chair
her cross stitching on her lap
half her attention on that half on the
tv which was showing some program about
astronomy or something
he tried to talk to her about the show
about the pattern she was working on
about anything but last night
but she just gave him one syllable
responses after a while he gave up and
stared at the television not really
seeing it
by later that afternoon his headache had
ebbed to a dull drone
and he was able to get down a ham
sandwich without throwing up
rachel still hadn't talked much but she
seemed a little more responsive
looking at him instead of through him
even laughing once at something on tv
mark laughed with her but it sounded
forced those dreams were still as vivid
as ever
finally he got to his feet and stretched
i think i'll go out for a drive he said
i need to get some fresh air
okay she didn't offer to come along he
wasn't sure if he was happy about that
or not
once outside in the brisk october breeze
he felt better the car started right up
thank christ
that mechanic had really earned his
money he backed out of the driveway and
cruised up the street
not thinking about going anywhere in
particular
except he was going somewhere in
particular casually he turned right onto
the two-lane highway that led out of the
main part of town
out into the woods beyond the city
limits mark turned up the radio and
cranked open all the windows
singing at the top of his voice trying
to drown out the knowledge of his
destination
hoping he would surprise himself when he
ended up there
the campground was nearly deserted it
was sunday and off season
he paid the five dollars at the gate
just the visitor fee for the spring
not the staying overnight fee the trees
grew together over the road as if
reaching for each other across a great
distance
little of the sunset tinge light
filtered through the branches
he felt a crawling sense of deja vu as
he guided the car through the tunnel of
forest
here it was a dirt path where the trees
weren't quite so thick
checking his rear view mirror to see if
anyone was around he pulled the car onto
the shoulder
he didn't want anyone to see it there
but there was nothing for it i won't be
long anyway
he thought her body had been heavy in
his dream
he remembered that his arms had ached
cursing under his breath he trudged
through the undergrowth
at last he reached the small cops where
he had dumped it
some of the branches of the bushes
looked broken askew as if someone had
been there recently
an animal maybe his hands were starting
to shake again
at first he couldn't believe that he was
seeing it he blinked and rubbed his eyes
just as he had earlier in front of the
closet but this time the illusion didn't
fade
a corner of a black garbage bag peeked
obviously from beneath a hastily
assembled pile of dead leaves and earth
that can't be her the rational part of
his mind might as well have whispered in
his ear
calm and soothing but there was somebody
in there damn it he closed his eyes for
a long moment staring into the brownish
void behind his lids
when i opened my eyes there will be
nothing there he opened them
it was still there it was nearly dark
the trunks of the trees around him
coalescing into indistinct smudges of
deep grey
he couldn't stay out here all night
someone might drive by his car
out on the road someone like a ranger
who might come in to investigate
but he had to know glancing back once
over his shoulder
seeing and hearing nothing except for
the burr of crickets and the croak of
frogs
he dropped to his knees and began
digging into the loose pile with his
clammy hands
once he had exposed a couple of square
feet of black plastic he hesitated his
fingers trembling
then all at once he tore a ragged hole
in the bag
rachel's dead face stared back at him
he immediately staggered to his feet and
vomited up the ham sandwich
his brain was racing there is no way he
thought
just no way i'm not crazy i didn't kill
her
i almost did but we stopped we calmed
down we stayed up until two or three in
the morning talking i held her hand
she got up and made me toast and coffee
but she was undoubtedly in the bag he
even thought he could see the faint
traces of bruising around her neck
maybe if i touch her she'll disappear or
it will turn out to be someone else
but he couldn't bring himself to touch
her he had touched the bag
and that it felt real enough but so did
my dream
choking back bile spitting into the
scattered leaves at his feet
he fished his phone out of his pants
pocket one way to solve this
he thought he dialed home and waited
rachel picked it up on the third ring
mark
yeah babe it's me his voice was wavering
unsteady
are you all right she didn't sound so
great either
for some reason that made mark even more
anxious
yeah fine i was just going to stop by
the store and i wondered if he needed
anything
it sounded like an excuse which was what
it was but somehow he sensed that it
would be okay
this one time no i just want you to come
home
had she been crying what's going on
rachel
and she did cry then great heaving sobs
that seemed to have been waiting for
their moment to escape
she took in huge hitching breaths
between words i just want you to come
home i dreamed you were dead
i dreamed i killed you his legs nearly
gave out under him
he began to realize how dark it was
getting how soon he would be less than
three feet from a corpse that he
wouldn't be able to see
a corpse that was definitely rachel even
though that was impossible
i'll be home very soon he said squinting
into the twilight
trying to make out the path on which
he'd come i'm coming home right now okay
okay please hurry she sniffled thickly
he stuffed the phone back in his pocket
and stole another look at the body
please let it be someone else please he
thought but of course it wasn't
rachel's slack face seemed to mock him
from the shadows
mark blundered his way through the woods
back toward his car
should he tell her and then a horrible
idea stopped him cold
what if she wasn't even there to tell
what if he really had killed her and had
just imagined that talk last night
imagined her in the kitchen this morning
hallucinations could look just like real
people couldn't they
he stood in the dark for a few minutes
his heart wheezing but then he dismissed
the thought tentatively
rachel had answered the phone hadn't she
hallucinations didn't answer phones
so what the hell was going on he reached
his car
now just a white shape through the trees
and he slid into the driver's seat
gripping the steering wheel as if to
confirm its solidity
he'd have to tell rachel what he'd seen
if she'd had the same dream
he didn't remember anything about the
drive home once there he sprinted from
the car
almost leaving the lights on and the
door wide open in his haste
she turned from the window when he
entered she'd been watching for him
they collided into each other's arms
hands and fingers squeezing
feeling and checking for the three
dimensions i'm sorry i was so hysterical
it's just that i
i know mark said i had the dreams too
her brow wrinkled and beneath it her
blurry gaze rested upon him
questioning what and just now
when i went out driving i found no
don't say it her whole body was shaking
i found something too the tone of her
voice gave it all away
jesus christ he breathed it was me
she nodded i dreamed that i stabbed you
and that i didn't know what to do so i
was burying you in the backyard under
the rose bushes
he envisioned the backyard of the house
they had shared for nearly all of their
marriage
it would be dark out there only a street
light from across the way
throwing an orange glow over the grass
there would be a shovel stuck in the
ground near the roses
the earth would be all churned up there
would be a hole about six feet long or
so
suddenly he felt like throwing up again
but he managed to tamp it down
i don't want to see it he said what's
happening what are we going to do
i don't know those bodies they're really
there aren't they
if the police come it can't be murder if
we're both still alive
saying it made him feel a little better
although he knew that it was [ __ ]
knew that a body was a body that somehow
they were both murderers
of themselves of each other they'd be
convicted in any court in the country
what if we're not still alive she said
it so quietly that he barely heard her
but he knew damn well what she had said
the thought had been nagging at the back
of his mind as well
but he hadn't consciously acknowledged
it he almost hated her for putting it
into words
that's impossible he said wishing he
felt as confident as he sounded
well what other explanation is there how
the hell would i know
he glared at her pale tear-stained face
why did he always have to think up
everything
she had a brain too didn't she i'm not
an expert on this type of thing you know
i'm just as [ __ ] confused as you are
she blinked he could tell she was
considering whether she should say
anything more
he wished she wouldn't i saw a show once
on tv
she said it was like i don't know
quantum physics or something
they said something about time overlaps
you know where stuff is happening at the
same time in different timelines you
know or
well that's just [ __ ] fabulous mark
spot very helpful
but maybe that's what's going on
rachel's voice had raised a notch to the
tone she always used when she was trying
to talk over him
when she thought he wasn't listening
maybe in one
time or whatever we didn't stop fighting
last night maybe that reality is sort of
manifesting itself
his head had started to pound again he
didn't give a [ __ ] about overlapping
time or different realities or any of
that [ __ ] she watched on the science
channel
all he knew was that there was a dead
body in the woods with obvious signs of
violence on it
that could be traced back to him just
shut up he said this is getting us
nowhere
all we have to do is deal with those
bodies but those bodies are us
she shrieked her voice climbing another
notch don't you see
in these other realities one of us is
dead what's going to happen to us the
real us
in this reality how can we unite the
realities again and will we still be
alive if we do that
i don't give a [ __ ] about any of that he
was getting angry but that was okay
that was good in fact she was prattling
on about this hypothetical physics crap
when there were practical things to be
done
he needed to light a fire under her ass
we just have to get rid of the bodies
both of us together i'm not going down
alone
but mark maybe if we can i said shut up
i think the bodies would go away on
their own if we could just figure out
and then it came upon him again like
that blinding drunk from the night
before
only now he was totally sober her throat
felt as brittle as a bird's skeleton
beneath his hands
and he wanted to crush it to drown out
her grating voice
in this reality and in every other it
was different this time because she
didn't have the kitchen knife in her
hand but that didn't matter
it was all him this time no other nasty
possibilities to assert themselves
he almost laughed at that when her body
went limp he stretched her out on the
sofa
closing her bulging eyes with his
fingertips she looked much the same as
her twin in the woods had except for the
bruises
they would come in time he plopped into
the easy chair
resting his chin on his hands now he had
two dead rachels to contend with
plus the body in the backyard that he
hadn't yet seen did he want to see it
he didn't think he did but the time
would come when it would be necessary
three murders three bodies strangely he
didn't feel any of the nervousness the
hopelessness the terrible anguish he'd
felt in his dream
why should he he was dead after all and
buried under the roses
[Music]
carson was drunk but not so drunk that
he didn't know it was time to get the
hell out of there
what's her name the girlfriend of the
guy who owned the house was drunk too
and she'd cornered him in one of the
upstairs bedrooms
she tasted like eggnog and pine scented
aerosol spray
her panties were black with tiny sprigs
of holly printed on them
afterwards she'd passed out across the
bed her mouth hanging half open pink
lipstick smeared across one cheek
carson had zipped his pants and crept
into the darkened hall
feeling a little dizzy and too warm in
his bulky black sweater
he didn't think anyone had seen him he
went downstairs where the ramones were
blasting out of the stereo
merry christmas baby i don't want to
fight tonight carson slipped through the
crowd of acquaintances and near
strangers
and went out the sliding glass door at
the back the deck outside was mercifully
empty
and though it was well past midnight the
shore front was ablaze with lightened
noise
christmas lights white and multi-colored
pulsed and flashed on all the ritzy
beach houses
while torches were balls of yellow flame
dancing in the humid floor tonight
the beach below looked darker the water
black and somehow inviting
so carson went toward it he hadn't
walked far before he was stricken with
the sudden urge to sit down
he heeded it immediately hoping he
wasn't going to throw up or pass out
maybe he was drunker than he thought he
breathed in and out a few times
experimentally
but no nausea manifested itself and he
sighed with relief
the sand was pleasantly cool beneath his
hands the water cold but barely reaching
him with its foamy tendrils
the surf eased in and then out the
woman's face appeared in the sand
where the water had been moments before
she was inches from his left hand
startled he tried to leap to his feet
but only succeeded in tangling his legs
together
and falling heavily on his side loose
sand puffed up in a corona around him
now he was sure he was drunker than he
thought
he looked at the spot in the wet sand
again the spot right near his hand print
the woman's face was unmistakable there
were deep pits where her eyes should be
and at the bottoms of the pits carson
swore he could make out a hint of long
black lashes
with grains of sand stuck in them here
and there
the nose protruded completely from the
sand the nostrils like tiny twin tunnels
that filled with water like irrigation
pipes as the tide washed in again
as it washed out carson could see the
mouth which appeared to be smiling
his senses dulled by alcohol carson
nevertheless realized the need for
intervention
the thought that the woman could be dead
did not really frighten him
nor was there any urgency in his
willingness to help
he was drunk and this seemed like an
interesting enough pastime
it was as simple as that crawling back
toward the face the ocean rushing in his
ears
he began digging in the sand with his
clawed fingers
first unearthing the eyes and mouth of
the buried woman then scooping out
handfuls of sand around the neck and
shoulders
she was a young woman from the looks of
it with blonde hair and skin that
appeared smooth as polished marble
she didn't look dead but carson couldn't
see how she could be alive
he'd removed almost all the sand from
around her head when she opened her eyes
they were bright those eyes
bright and hot and yellow as dual suns
glowing orbs of flame in the darkness
he reared back his capacity for shock
seemingly returning
the ocean was roaring behind him the
sound of a furious and wrathful god
and he looked over his shoulder at it
mostly so that he could look away from
those eyes
the candlelight eyes of the woman in the
sand and then he saw the water rising up
in a wave
black and gigantic so tall that it was
blotting out the moon
icy drops rained down upon his forehead
and then the ocean fell upon him
dark and heavy and hungry
he rolled out of bed his feet making a
damp sounding splat on the hardwood
floor
he was naked and he noticed his skin
smelled vaguely of sweat and salt
and hint of fishiness the beach
he looked around confused yes right
there by the hamper was the black
sweater
and the jeans and socks he'd been
wearing the night before
they were still wet and sand clung to
them in grainy white clumps
carson dragged himself into the bathroom
and stood under the shower for nearly 15
minutes
letting cold water pound down on his
aching muscles
it was saturday only a week before
christmas he had planned on doing some
shopping today
maybe head over to the frame shop to see
if those dozen paintings were ready for
pickup yet
but at the moment he felt so wretched
that all he wanted to do was brew up a
giant pot of coffee and zone out in
front of the tv
the day was mostly shot anyway since
he'd slept so late
feeling a little better now that he'd
effectively postponed the day's
responsibilities
he turned off the water and toweled
himself dry pulling on the
paint-spattered t-shirt and sweatpants
that had been hanging limpy on the
doorknob since sometime last week
as he padded back out through the living
room he remembered the sound that had
woken him
the flap of the mail slot so he diverted
his route to pick up the few scattered
envelopes
junk crap catalogs he sighed and headed
for the trash can in the kitchen
at the bottom of the pile was a
handwritten envelope and he glanced at
it without much interest
mr carson sloan the top line red and
very neat black ink
he flipped the envelope over no return
address
he wondered if it was a christmas card
from somebody tossing the rest of the
mail aside
he tore open the flap of the mysterious
envelope and pulled out two pages of
stiff blue paper
dear mr sloane the letter began i have
seen many examples of your portrait work
both in collector's magazines and in
person at the formby gallery show this
past july
i feel that you have the qualities i
desire in an artist and i would like to
commission you to paint a portrait of my
wife
carson raised his eyebrows a commission
would be a huge boon right now
the work had dried up somewhat after an
initial flurry of interest in his first
gallery show
he read on i would like very much for
you to be a guest in my house
for as long as it takes to complete the
portrait all of your expenses will of
course be taken care of
and you will be amply compensated for
the painting
the letter writer then named a some that
made carson whistle low between his
teeth
it was more than anyone had ever paid
for any of his paintings
in fact it was far more than his
paintings had fetched altogether
he kept reading his skin going hot in
his growing excitement
apparently the guy was richer than god
and lived with his wife and servants in
a remote chateau
on some tiny island in the gulf of
mexico in his neat hand the benefactor
described the surroundings
mentioning the pleasing north light in
the room where carson would be working
then detailing travel arrangements
including a private plane that would
retrieve carson from the airport
and would return him to the mainland
once the painting was completed
please contact me as soon as possible if
you agree to these terms
i hope that we can have a mutually
agreeable working relationship
and i look forward to your answer the
letter was signed
tom lancaster an address was spelled out
beneath the signature
after he'd finished reading carson
nearly laughed out loud
if this proposition was on the up and up
then the gods were certainly smiling
down on him today
and had evidently chosen to ignore his
transgressions at last night's christmas
party
a holiday miracle he said to himself and
chuckled
then he read the letter again his heart
beating faster with each paragraph
apparently this tom lancaster was
looking forward to carson's reply
and dammit that reply was going to be
lightning fast in coming
forgetting about the pot of coffee in
the tv carson grabbed a pen and some old
stationary out of a drawer
and sat down at the kitchen table to
write
he dropped the letter into the box with
a hopeful little flip checking the hatch
three times to make sure it had fallen
all the way down
as he walked back to his apartment
feeling better than he had all week
he happened to glance over at the
decorations festooning the small
cathedral across the street
and there she was the woman in the sand
she was actually more of a girl than a
woman he decided now that he could see
her in a more normal context
her hair was very blonde and pulled back
in a loose ponytail
she wore an orange coat at first carson
thought she had been staring at him but
when he looked at her again she had
turned her head
and was climbing the steps toward the
open doors of the church
he felt a little chill and imagined he
smelled salt for a moment
but then he chided himself maybe he'd
seen the girl before
walking around the neighborhood maybe
he'd seen her without registering it
then later dreamed about her
stuff like that happened all the time
didn't it and she was very beautiful
now that he had seen her properly so he
might very well have noticed her at some
earlier date
still moving with the jaunty bounce he
crossed the street and went into the
church
he didn't really know why he was
following her but it seemed the logical
thing to do
there had been some christmas pageant in
the cathedral that morning but it was
over now
and only a few people whispered among
the darkened pews
even after his eyes had adjusted to the
dimness carson couldn't see the girl at
first
the light was shifting and spectral
casting phantoms upon the walls and
statues
candles flickered and the gray glow from
outside was filtered as rainbows through
the high stained glass windows
then he spotted her she was up near the
altar drifting slowly as if in a trance
moving sideways with a graceful shuffle
that made it appear that she was
floating a few inches above the floor
carson could only see a quarter of her
face a pale cheek stained yellow by
candlelight
he drew closer trying to keep his own
footsteps quiet
the girl seemed to be praying at any
rate her lips were moving
silently and one hand was pressed to the
lapel of her coat
carson decided to speak to her and he
took a few steps closer
but then he saw clearly what she was
doing
the candles at the front of the church
had been purchased and lit by
parishioners
who hoped that the candle flame would
speed their prayers toward the heavens
their prayers as carson knew inevitably
involved loved ones who were ill or
dying
the blonde girl was looking at each
candle in turn muttering to herself
her eyes were very wrapped and focused
on her work
she would skip this candle and then that
one but then with her shuffling sideways
movements
she would stop in front of one that she
had chosen by some criteria known only
to her
and then she would lick her thumb and
forefinger hold them over the candle
flame
and very deliberately pinch her fingers
over the wick
snuffing it out with a wisp of smoke and
the faint odor of burning wax
carson disturbed turned and left the
church the day after christmas
carson found himself seated on a plastic
chair in a tiny regional airport
a battered gym bag and a small suitcase
resting between his feet
the weather had turned very cold
oppressive the sky
seemed a blackening bowl closing down
upon the earth
the effect was unsettling through the
massive windows
the airport was nearly empty and carson
stared out at the tarmac
trying to get excited about all the
money he would soon be making
but instead distracted by thoughts of
the blonde girl who he hadn't seen since
that day in the cathedral
he had been waiting a little more than
half an hour when he heard echoing
footsteps very loud
approaching him from behind the man when
he appeared was chunky and dower
dressed in black slacks and a simple
white polo shirt that gave the
impression of a uniform
carson stood understanding that this was
one of tom lancaster's servants
specific travel arrangements had arrived
in his mailbox only two days before
carson nodded to the man but said
nothing and did not offer his hand to
shake
the man didn't speak either simply
motioned for carson to follow
the plane ride was only an hour and
uneventful save for the impending stormy
weather
the man who had picked him up at the
airport sat in back his face
expressionless
the pilot had said a brief hello but
then fallen silent also
carson who wasn't much of a talker
anyway looked out the plane's window
and saw stiff peaks of white churning up
the gulf and the sky growing darker by
the minute
by the time they landed the sun had
nearly set and carson saw little of the
island itself as he stepped off the
plane onto a small patch of blacktop
the wind was harsh and cold rain had
begun to fall
he dug another sweater from his bag
shivering
when the pilot spoke near his ear carson
almost jumped out of his skin
there'll be a car waiting for you just
on the other side of that building he
said
pointing to a small structure some yards
away
then his duties apparently fulfilled he
turned on his heel and climbed back into
the plane
carson was struck by a profound sense of
isolation as he crossed the tarmac
there seemed to be no sound other than
the wind through far away and unseen
trees
and the beat of the rain on the ground
the lights that shone down on the little
island airport were yellow and too
bright
like interrogation spotlights he felt
exposed out in the open
and walked faster toward the building
pulling his sweater tight around himself
just as the pilot had promised a
charcoal grey car idled in the parking
lot on the other side of the structure
its windshield wipers thumping back and
forth it was too dark for carson to see
the driver
but he made his way toward the car
arranging his expression to display
friendliness
a look of belonging here before he had
got all the way to the car the driver's
side door opened and another man got out
dressed in the same outfit as the other
two men
carson couldn't help but be impressed
his patron evidently had a whole fleet
of servants at his disposal
he slid into the vehicle which was
expensive but not showy
without a word the driver started the
engine and turned out of the lot onto a
dark road with trees pressing close on
both sides
after 10 minutes carson finally spoke is
there anyone else on the island
he hadn't seen any other houses or any
signs of human habitation at all
just the trees crowding in like vast
green armies
only mr lancaster and his wife answered
the driver somewhat tersely
and us of course it's a very small
island
carson was going to ask how they got
their food and what they did for fun
with no one else around
but the driver's tone seemed to
discourage further inquiry
so carson settled back against the seat
and stared out into the dark again
the house loomed up in the headlights
less than five minutes later
and carson found himself straining his
eyes to take it all in
unable to wrap his mind around the size
of the thing
it towered out of the ground as though
it had grown there an oddly organic
structure of wood and natural stone
and seemingly acre upon acre of glass
all the windows on the lower floors were
ablaze with light
and carson suppressed a smile if he was
going to be staying in this palace then
he'd certainly take his sweet time
finishing the painting two or even three
weeks could easily become a month or two
of luxury
being waited on by servants eating the
best food swimming in the no doubt
fabulous pool
lying on the beach during off hours with
a cocktail in hand
yes his life was definitely looking up
this was all far
far more than he could ever have
imagined the car swept through the
inevitable wrought iron gates
and came to a stop before the massive
edifice the driver got out and came
around to open carson's door
yes he thought he could definitely get
used to this
he climbed the front steps which looked
to be made of marble while the driver
followed with his bags
the front doors were standing open and
warm light flooded out
flickering like the glow from a huge
fireplace
a slim diminutive man was silhouetted in
the doorway
dressed in a casual grey suit carson
knew immediately that this must be mr
lancaster
the man was much younger than carson had
pictured him probably only in his
mid-thirties
with auburn hair cut in a hip european
style he was smiling broadly
displaying teeth that looked perfect not
through expensive dentistry but rather
fortuitous genetics
mr sloane lancaster stepped forward his
arms extended
welcome i hope it wasn't too much of a
trial coming all the way out here in
this weather
not at all carson shook hands unable to
help himself from liking the man
immediately
and please call me carson of course and
you must call me tom
he peered over carson's head at the
driver briggs here will take your things
up to your room and i'll take you to
meet the lovely subject of your
impending masterpiece
he gestured for carson to follow as he
turned and went into the house
carson quickly crossed the threshold
after his host trying not to gape at the
tasteful opulence that surrounded him
briggs disappeared up a narrow staircase
that was almost hidden behind a large
grandfather clock
we've laid out a late supper so i hope
you're hungry tom said
glancing over his shoulder and smiling
brilliantly again
i'm sure you'll find yourself well
looked after here yes i can see that
already
carson said they entered a long dining
room whose walls were lined with
paintings
mostly portraits but carson spotted a
few more modern abstract pieces in the
collection
the dining table in the center of the
room was large but not so large as to be
impersonal
in fact despite its size carson thought
the whole room rather cozy
a white brick fireplace glowed cheerily
at one end
darling said tom this is carson sloane a
resident artist
a woman that carson hadn't noticed
before rose from an armchair before the
fire
and began to come toward them she too
seemed very young
her pale skin flawless her blonde hair
pulled back to accentuate her
aristocratic forehead
she was clad in a simple black wrap
dress with long sleeves
and wore it with no jewelry except for a
small diamond ring on the third finger
of her left hand
and she was carson realized the spitting
image of the woman in the sand
the woman he'd seen snuffing out candles
in the cathedral
for a moment he froze his sense of
reality deserting him
what was she doing here what kind of
game was she playing with him
she must have known about the commission
and flown over to spy on him
to check him out before he came to the
house but why would she do that
she didn't know him from adam the whole
scenario sounded incredible but what
other explanation could there be
then as she emerged fully from the
shadows carson saw to his chagrin that
it was not the same woman at all
the resemblance was striking that was
true close enough so that the two of
them could have been sisters
but not exactly the same something in
the eyes was different
and the turn of her mouth this is
victoria
tom was saying seemingly unaware of
carson's discomfort
the artist offered his hand to her
automatically hoping that his palm
wasn't sweating
she took his hand in hers and squeezed
it her smile less ostentatious than her
husband's
but just as welcoming in its way perhaps
even more so
i hope i'll be a model worthy of your
talents mr sloane she
said she had a wonderful voice soft and
throaty
and carson found his skin tingling at
the sound of it
he knew before he even started that this
would be the best portrait he would ever
paint
how could it be otherwise please it's
carson
he said and i'll try my hardest to
capture your radiance on canvas
i hope my skills are up to the task he
thought he sounded overly stilted and
formal but his words seemed to please
her
well shall we have a bite tom gestured
toward the table
i don't know about you carson but i'm
absolutely ravenous
now that you mention it i'm starving
carson replied realizing as he said it
that it was true
he hadn't eaten since that morning
before he'd gone to the airport
he glanced at mrs lancaster victoria and
she smiled again
a secret smile this time that seemed
meant only for him
that night nestled among perfumed
cushions in a huge four poster bed
he dreamed of the party he'd gone to a
week ago the one where he'd slept with
what's-his-name's girlfriend
only this time the girl was victoria and
instead of passing out halfway through
the act
she stayed wide awake urging him on
whispering commands in his ear with that
throaty voice
he obeyed her without question his body
aching with the contact
and then suddenly they were both naked
on the beach running in the sand like
crazed animals
victoria was laughing into the night the
sound punctuated by flares from the
torches
that surrounded them with wild orange
light
carson rolled on top of her and she sunk
into the sand shrieking laughter all the
while
panicked carson began digging to free
her not stopping to wonder how she could
laugh when her nose and mouth were
packed
full of sand just needing to save her
but her laughter grew louder and mocking
as he dug and got no closer to her
a familiar roar in his ears alerted him
to the encroaching sea
behind him and he just had time to turn
before the water fell on him
like a solid curtain of wet cement
cutting off his oxygen
making him senseless to all but the
keening sound of victoria's laughter
he snapped awake his fingers still
curled and claw-like before him
the room was dim but a reassuring
moonlight peered in from around the
drapes
helping him to establish his
surroundings the house was quiet and
still
the only sound a steady tick from the
mantle clock across the room
he tried to relax shifting his position
among the cushions
it had only been a dream he was far from
that horrible beach
safe in a beautiful house and clearly
among friends
still it was several hours before he was
able to fall asleep again
the next day he was allowed to sleep
late and then a servant came with
breakfast on a silver tray
after carson had eaten he cleaned
himself up and followed another servant
downstairs to the room where he would be
working
carson had of course brought some of his
own materials but he saw that the
lancasters had planned for everything
the room where he was to paint already
had a top of the line easel setup
a set of the finest brushes laid out in
a wooden box
brand new tubes of every imaginable hue
and large unopened bottles of various
oils and mediums
as well as a selection of solvents
carson was a little overwhelmed
and also a bit ashamed of his own rather
scruffy supplies which he'd thrown
haphazardly into his gym bag
inspecting the things tom had left for
him carson decided to just ditch his old
stuff
and work exclusively with the new which
was of a far higher quality than he
could normally afford
he was examining the already primed
canvas on the easel when he heard soft
footsteps behind him
he whirled and saw victoria lancaster
standing there clad only in a blue silk
robe
i hope i didn't startle you she said
carson couldn't help his eyes traveling
up and down her body
he felt his face grow hot uh no i was
just you know checking out the materials
the supplies i mean his blush deepened
she didn't seem to notice i hope you'll
have everything you need
tom wasn't sure what to get so he sort
of bought some of everything
she smiled brightly he's very thorough
yeah
well carson wasn't sure what to say next
so he pretended to be engrossed in the
contents of the turpentine bottle
tom did tell you this would be a nude
portrait didn't he
carson closed his eyes forcing himself
to stay calm
he had started to sweat even though the
room was cool
no he didn't as a matter of fact well
i hope it won't make you too
uncomfortable her eyes twinkled
carson still couldn't look at her
directly he had of course painted plenty
of nude women in his day
both girlfriends and paid models but
this was different somehow
he breathed slowly through his nose not
at all it's a
common subject of mine this wasn't
entirely the truth but it was close
enough to it to reassure her he figured
although really it was he who needed the
reassuring
yes the one at your gallery show was
most extraordinary victoria said
she was right behind him now it was that
painting that gave tom the idea for a
nude
and what tom wants she let the sentence
dangle but carson could hear the wicked
smirk in her voice
then he heard another sound a soft
whisper-like fabric sliding down a body
and pooling on the floor
then her voice came again shall we get
started
he wasn't sure how he managed to do it
but finally carson turned to face her
she was trim and attractively pale her
skin glowing yellow in the north light
from the large windows
he wanted to look at her breasts but he
forced his gaze up to her eyes
he was here to paint her and he couldn't
afford distractions
he swallowed hard and affected a
business-like tone
any particular pose you had in mind he
asked
well i'll leave that up to you she said
clearly amused by his awkwardness
you're the artist so he proceeded to
pose her
trying to contain his haste wanting more
than anything to be across the room in
front of the canvas
victoria barely spoke obeying his
command to put that arm there that foot
here
tilt the head a little farther to the
right at last he had her positioned in
the way he wanted
and he quickly mixed together a dab of
burnt umber and some turpentine
then chose a large brush from the box
and set to work on a rough underpainting
he didn't see tom all day and even
though he wondered why he thought it
might be presumptuous to ask his
whereabouts
the hours flew by and by dinner time
carson had blocked in the entire
painting and was quite happy with how it
was turning out
a bell rang somewhere in the house and
victoria got lazily to her feet
stretching obviously in no hurry to put
her robe back on
that'll be dinner served she said
finally shrugging back into her clothes
i'll go get dressed while you clean up
here do you remember how to get to the
dining room
carson said he did he tried not to stare
at victoria's retreating back as she
sashayed out of the room
once she was gone he took one huge deep
breath and let it out
then he laughed out loud this was going
to be a very interesting few weeks to
say the least
the days continued with little variation
painting all day
then dinner with tom and victoria on the
weekend he was given a break while the
lancasters flew to the mainland for some
charity function
carson spent most of the time poking
around the massive house
or watching the movie screen-sized
television in the sitting room on the
second floor
when monday came he was back at work he
was no longer
quite as disoriented by victoria's naked
presence although her stunning beauty
and flirtatious manner still had the
power to befuddle him
victoria herself had grown more
comfortable and easygoing as the days
passed
and chatted with him about various
topics as she posed
even occasionally laughing at his lame
jokes the painting progressed nicely
and carson could already tell that it
was going to be his very best portrait
eventually he felt enough at ease with
victoria to ask her why tom never seemed
to be around to look in on them
oh he's never in the house during the
day she said waving a dismissive hand
carson thought he detected a note of
forced casualness in her voice
he mostly likes to mess about on the
other side of the island
carson had left it there but his brain
had raced for hours afterwards
was there some reason tom deliberately
stayed away
he thought of victoria's lingering
glances and seductive smiles
what harm would it do really to return
her obvious interest
if what she said was true tom was on the
other side of the island
and the fact that she'd made a point of
mentioning his absence suggested that
she would probably be open to carson's
advances
perhaps the lancasters had one of those
open marriages he had always heard about
but no he was paid to do a job here and
he couldn't risk screwing it up for a
piece of tail
even if the tail was as delectable as
victoria's
this gig was paying a huge amount of
money and such a prestigious commission
would undoubtedly advance his flagging
career
he just couldn't take the chance
carson's steely resolve lasted until
thursday of that week the previous
afternoon had seen the finish of the
second layer of flesh tones
the painting was still relatively
sketchy but was shaping up to be as tom
had predicted
a masterpiece victoria still naked had
stood behind carson
admiring the portrait gently touching
the back of his neck with her fingers
he had clenched his teeth together
trying to ignore the tingle of her skin
against his
that night in bed he could think of
nothing but her taut pale body
and his hand had worked feverishly
beneath the covers he knew he would not
be able to resist her for much longer
thursday morning victoria strode into
the room in her robe as she usually did
but today she carried a bottle of wine
and two glasses
i thought we could celebrate the
progress you've been making she said in
response to his question and glance
carson knew immediately where all of
this was going to end up but he
resignedly let himself be led over to
the chase that victoria had been posing
on
she sat very close to him so close that
the blue silk of her robe overlapped the
paint spattered denim of his jeans
she filled his wine glass almost to the
rim her sparkling eyes never leaving his
cheers she said two full glasses later
she reached over and took carson's hand
guiding it under her robe to the cleft
between her legs
even though carson had been painting
this same body in some detail over the
past two weeks
when he touched her she still felt new
to him and thrilling
in seconds they were intertwined the
silk robe whispering to the floor
the glasses falling from their hands and
shattering merrily to pieces
he had never experienced anything like
it and even many hours later
as he lay in bed how he had managed to
paint afterwards and then face tom
across the dinner table he still
couldn't fathom
he kept reliving it over and over in his
mind remembering the taste of her
the sound of her little cries the feel
of her body pressing up to meet his
she was extraordinary the painting began
to take on more of a finished look over
the next several days
although when carson thought about it he
wasn't quite sure how he was getting any
work done at all
he and victoria were at each other
almost from the moment that she walked
into the studio each morning
and sometimes they would lie for hours
on the chase or the floor
sweating and spent and stare into each
other's eyes until the inevitable hunger
struck again
this blissful arrangement went on for
two more weeks and judging by tom's
endlessly friendly demeanor at dinner
he didn't suspect a thing hopefully
carson thought tom wouldn't suspect a
thing until
after the painting was finished and
after he'd collected his hefty fee and
made his way back to his normal life on
the mainland
one night in the middle of the fourth
week carson heard a soft knock on his
bedroom door
when he rose to open it he found
victoria standing there in a different
planar silk robe
her eyes puffy and red from crying
carson looked past her out into the hall
are you crazy he whispered harshly what
are you doing here
we had a fight she said sniffling she
didn't seem concerned at all
i'm sorry i just wanted to see you he
pulled her roughly inside and closed the
door as quietly as he could
by the time he had turned to face her
she had already crossed the room and sat
down on his bed
what did you fight about he asked
because if tom knows about us then i am
seriously [ __ ]
victoria looked up at him a wicked smile
curling her upper lip
what if he did know with one fluid
motion she slid the robe off her
shoulders
she was naked underneath her skin
glowing softly in the dimness
she lay back against the tousled covers
you shouldn't be so nervous
come here carson's sudden and unbearable
lust was also spiked with anger
and resentment of her attitude don't you
care about how this might affect me
he hissed still trying to keep his voice
low but finding it very difficult
we can't do this now not with tom in the
house he might come looking for you
he stayed by the door further enraged by
her mocking smile
and his erection which was becoming
painful he clenched his fist by his
sides
trying to bring himself under control
does this get you off is that it
things got boring already and now you're
trying to spice them up with a little
danger
danger does have its charms she purred
lazily circling one nipple with her
finger
carson put his hand on the doorknob all
right victoria please get out
i'll see you in the studio tomorrow just
like always he turned the knob but
didn't open the door
victoria made no move to leave instead
she crossed her legs languidly and
folded her hands behind her head
this could look very bad if tom were to
come down the hall right now
she said what do you think would happen
would he be angry
slap me around a little or would he want
to join us do you think
you [ __ ] carson had never felt quite so
helpless in his entire life
he was on an island with no way off
practically at the mercy of this woman
and her husband
even if he could get to the phone who
would he call a horrible thought crossed
his mind then
are you setting me up he asked his hand
sweating on the doorknob
the sound of rapid footsteps in the hall
made his stomach drop down to his shoes
this was bad very bad carson looked
frantically left and right
searching for some escape someplace to
hide he even looked to victoria pleading
silently with her
don't do this to me i thought i was your
friend
she simply smiled giving him no quarter
swearing
carson lunged toward the closet but it
was already too late
the doorknob was turning he cursed
himself for not locking it
but what if he had he was only
postponing the inevitable
victoria the word was almost a roar and
for a moment carson was stunned at the
sound of it
emerging as it did from the throat of
the small and previously good-natured
tom lancaster
as victoria's husband burst through the
door though he looked anything but small
and good-natured
he looked feral carson stood to the
right of the open door
praying fervently that he would somehow
become invisible
victoria seemed not to have reacted at
all and still lay sprawled on carson's
bed
nude and completely calm hello darling
she said
i knew it i knew something like this
would happen again
tom was wearing flannel pajama pants and
his normally immaculate hair was
sticking up in back
under different circumstances he might
have looked comical but now his
disheveled appearance contributed to his
look of utter madness
and yet you keep on hiring them victoria
said
she looked at her fingernails apparently
unconcerned by her husband's wrath
never again victoria do you hear me i
put up with it for so long but it will
never
happen again it was only then that
carson noticed to his horror
that tom's hand was curled around a
small black pistol
which he had been holding almost behind
his back
carson tensed his body to run but tom
whipped his head toward him
never he said his mad eyes dancing in
the dimness
he then raised the pistol turned his
head and shot his wife twice in the
chest
carson felt waves of unreality washing
over him as victoria's body snapped back
as her blood sprayed across the sheets
he'd been sleeping on less than an hour
ago
the report from the shots rang in his
ears his legs buckled under him
and he went to his knees on the
floorboards his vision
swam but he was able to watch victoria's
limbs shudder convulsively before
falling still forever
her silk robe was still beneath her half
on and half off the bed in his confusion
carson thought of his painting which
would never be finished now
the realization made him far sadder than
it probably should have
considering his death was likely
imminent and you
tom was towering above him the gun
clasped tightly in a hand that looked
steady as a rock
carson looked up slowly barely able to
register what was happening
tom's voice came again like a gods from
on high
i've got worse in store for you he said
carson cringed not understanding the
import of the sentence
and then tom's gun hand was swinging and
carson felt a hard crack against the
side of his head
then again blackness
when he came too for a second he
couldn't even tell if he had actually
awakened
because it was just as dark with his
eyes closed as open
the only noise was the rushing of the
sea very close by
but somehow hollow sounding his head was
killing him
he couldn't remember exactly what had
happened at first his memories were
fuzzy like fragments of dreams
slowly though images filtered into the
darkness before his eyes
victoria and blood and the insane
expression of his benefactor
holding a pistol in one steady hand
carson stumbled to his feet suddenly
terrified
his consciousness faltered for a moment
and he reached out for a handhold to
keep from falling
his fingers met what felt like wet sand
very tightly packed
when he had regained his equilibrium he
began feeling around in the dark
the wet sand was all around him
extending as far above his head as he
could reach
with dawning horror he realized he must
be in some kind of pit
what the [ __ ] was going on calm now calm
he told himself
he had to think he had to concentrate he
looked up toward the top of his prison
he could barely make anything out it was
so dark he closed his eyes
shook his head a few times hoping to
clear it the dull ache where the gunbud
had hit him made him dizzy and nauseated
when he opened his eyes again and looked
up he thought he could see the barest
suggestion of a ragged lip and beyond it
a blacker sky
if he focused very hard he almost
fancied he could see stars twinkling in
the distance
this might however have been his
imagination
something that definitely wasn't his
imagination was the sound of the ocean
which was getting appreciably louder
carson didn't know quite what was going
on or exactly where he was
but he knew he had to get the hell out
of here now tom might be roaming around
somewhere nearby
his lust for blood still not sated he
hooked his fingers into claws and tried
to climb up the vertical sides of the
pit
but after a few frenzied attempts he had
nothing but a face full of sand for his
troubles
he then thought of tunneling his way out
and proceeded to dig at a small section
of wall
but in due course it quickly collapsed
on itself and carson gave up exhausted
should he call for help maybe he wasn't
far from the house
maybe one of the servants would hear and
take pity on him then again maybe tom
would appear at the top of the pit
point his pistol downwards and blow
carson's brains all over the sand
he decided to keep his mouth shut for
now the rush of the sea was getting very
loud but the significance of this didn't
quite dawn on carson until a second or
two later
when he was suddenly splashed with
freezing water raining down on him from
above
in an instant he understood tom had
thrown him in a pit on the beach
and as soon as the tide came in spurred
on by the thought of a slow drowning
carson began clawing frantically at the
walls again tearing out handfuls of sand
and flinging them in piles at his feet
victoria's voice kept echoing through
his head like a mantra
telling him how tom liked to spend his
days poking around at the other end of
the island
is that what tom had been doing digging
a pit in preparation
something tom had said before shooting
victoria came back to him
i knew something like this would happen
again was this beach studded with the
corpses of other men who had gotten a
little too friendly with victoria
the thought pushed him to greater action
and carson dug and dug until his fingers
were raw
but still the lip of the pit got no
closer and now even more water was
beginning to spill into the hole
cold and salty in his eyes and mouth
finally he fell back against the wet pit
floor
wheezing and choking he could have
screamed and even sucked in his breath
to do so
but in the end he couldn't quite bring
himself to make a sound
he was still afraid of tom hearing him
although he had to admit to himself that
being shot would probably be a quicker
death than drowning
he was still lying there panting when he
thought he heard a voice
coming to him from beneath the now
deafening roar of the ocean in his ears
he got to his feet wet sand squishing
between his toes
and cocked his head to listen at first
he couldn't hear anything
but then it came again carson it said
it was a woman's voice his heart
quickened
the only woman on the island who knew
his name was victoria
and tom had shot her dead he had seen it
with his own eyes hadn't he
so it was either her ghost calling to
him which was honestly pretty unlikely
or carson was losing his mind this
latter scenario
as much as he hated to admit it was
probably far closer to the truth
but then a third option occurred to him
one that made his fingers curl into
tight fists
maybe tom had only pretended to kill
victoria as part of some elaborate game
the couple was playing with him
the fact that there was no apparent
motive for any of this didn't make
carson's blood boil any less
as he stood there wet and shivering and
seething with growing fury
he thought he saw a vague movement far
above him he squinted up into the
darkness
a face had appeared at the edge of the
pit round and lit by what appeared to be
candlelight
it was a woman's face victoria he
screamed up at her
that [ __ ] had set him up right from the
beginning and he had fallen for it like
the sucker he was
she had come on to him encouraged him
even made a point of telling him about
tom being away
but then the light above him flickered
and he saw that it wasn't victoria who
stared down at him
it was her the woman from the beach back
home
the woman who'd been snuffing out prayer
candles at the church
for a moment carson was seized with a
horrible sense of dislocation
and he thought he might pass out what
the hell was that girl doing here
when he'd regained some of his composure
he managed to sputter
who are you i'm moira she said
and carson realized it was the first
time he'd really heard her speak
her voice was soft yet somehow boomed
and vibrated like a huge brass bell
what's going on another rush of water
poured into the hole
and carson covered his face to keep the
salty sea out of his eyes
when he had recovered he looked up to
see moira still peering down at him
as though the water had not affected her
don't worry carson
she said the sound of the ocean seeming
to strengthen her words rather than
drown them out
when the tide comes in you can just wait
for the pit to fill with water and then
swim to the top
all you have to do is wait carson he
thought he saw her smile in the weird
flickering candlelight that illuminated
her face
then another wave came cold and black
and crushing
carson blinked and breathed in suddenly
coughing and spitting out the sand that
filled his mouth
it was still dark but now the stars
seemed much closer
a dazzling white spray across the
heavens his wet clothes seemed to press
down upon him pinning him to the ground
at last he struggled to a sitting
position still hacking up sand and salt
water
he turned his head to the left and right
wincing at the pain
which felt like a mallet blow to the
nape of his neck
he was on the beach back home behind
him houses lined the dunes their windows
brightly lit
shadows moving behind them like black
paper cutouts
he staggered to his feet how could he be
back here
had the lancaster's plane brought him
back from the island
he turned in a complete circle the house
just behind him was ablaze with light
and music and laughter
the sliding glass doors were open onto
the deck which was flanked by gaily
burning torches
as carson watched a silhouette separated
itself from the others
inside and made its way out onto the
deck
for a moment the man's features were
illuminated by the flames
but then they plunged into darkness
again as the figure came down the deck
steps
and began walking on the beach toward
carson
no no no carson thought wanting to move
to run
but finding himself rooted to the spot i
shouldn't even be here i'm supposed to
be on the lancaster's island
again he tried to hobble away but his
legs felt as though they were encased
and led
he looked down and nearly screamed
because she was there
moira the girl in the sand her laughing
face protruded only an inch from the
ground
as did her hands which encircled his
ankles like steel leg irons
carson began shaking his head no longer
sure what was real anymore
not even sure if he was real anymore and
then the figure from the house was
before him
and the figure was what's his name the
guy who'd given that party that carson
had been to forever ago
and what's-his-name's face was nearly
purple with rage
did you think i didn't see you with
shelley the guy said and carson just had
time to think so that's what her name
was
shelley before what's-his-name punched
him hard in the mouth
carson went sprawling into the sand and
found himself face to
face with moira who had been in the sand
that first night when he'd been drunk
who had been in the church stifling all
those people's prayers who had somehow
been on the island saving him
and all so that she could bring him back
here to meet his fate in this appointed
place
for a second he wanted to ask what's his
name if he could see her too
but he thought better of it he already
knew what the answer would be anyway
he thought of beautiful moira in the
cathedral that day pinching out the
candles with her fingers
cutting off the lives of the people for
whom the candles had been lit
like one of the mythological fates she
chose the right moment to sever the
thread
carson realized this now and the eyes of
the girl in the sand seemed to light up
with tiny flames
as though she had read his mind and was
pleased by what she had found there
carson had a clear vision of a burning
candle and a moira's graceful fingers
poised above the wick
then he felt what's-his-name's hand on
the back of his head and the cold shock
of seawater covering his face
a deep breath through the nose a brief
struggle another onrushing torrent of
darkness
moira's fingers closed over the flame
and the smoke spiraled up and out
until there was nothing left but the
twinkle of the stars and the smell of
cooling wax
you